when you come to a store like this
already work with the tailor that there
for you so don't just try it on and say
okay I'll do get them to make sure it's
perfect but you do you feel good in the
[ __ ] I mean feel like it actually
somewhat fits do you feel expensive not
yet
you will stylist tan France is best
known for his role as the fashion expert
on the Netflix series queer eye the
award-winning reality program has been
recognized for its celebration of
diversity and acceptance in the LGBTQ
community France details his life before
the show's success and his recently
released memoir naturally tan June is LG
l BG TQ Pride Month and France shares
his own journey to acceptance as part of
our series
note to self and we met him at the
Parsons School of Design here in New
York City
dear tan for the longest time you
thought you have to fake who you are as
a child growing up in a small English
town you are sometimes attacked for
simply being Brown the fear of racism
was constant you grew up learning to
hide any trait that might give away your
sexuality just dealing with your
ethnicity was problem enough
[Music]
now at 17 you think you need to run away
from the world that you've grown up in
because you are a gay Pakistani man it's
getting time to start considering
marriage to a woman and you're afraid
that people start to figure you out if
you're frantic about having to hide who
you are do not settle everything is
about to change soon you'll discover
Salt Lake City a place where you feel
more comfortable than you've ever felt
before
there you'll meet the perfect person and
fall in love though in some ways you and
Rob couldn't be more different he was
raised Mormon and grow up as a cowboy on
a legit ranch you're find that you have
the same values he will understand you
better than anyone you'll want to uproot
your whole life to be with him moving to
America is a huge decision go with your
heart take the risk you and Rob will go
into marriage with the same expectations
that divorce is not an option and your
commitment is for life your husband will
show you what it means to feel
acceptance and unconditional love
you are desperately ambitious within the
first few weeks in the US somebody will
offer you a job that allows you to stay
here you'll start your fashion business
decades earlier than expected there will
be many hard times and many bad times
but that doesn't mean it's time to give
up when bad things happen experience
them accept them for what they are and
then allow them to push you harder to
create the life that you truly want
there will come a time when the pressure
becomes too much and your anxiety and
depression will consume you
one day when driving home from work
you'll consider driving off a bridge
young yourself you need to calm the down
you've taken on way too much and you
think there is no way out you fear that
this is the end of everything but it is
not you will find a way out of this
darkness soon what sooner than you think
you'll get a call from a thing called
Netflix don't worry it's totally legit
and way bigger than you could ever
imagine this call will change your life
they'll ask you to be the fashion expert
on a show called where I listen nobody
wants to have sex with you when you're
wearing pyjamas like this okay so your
closet we've kept some of the good stuff
that you had it in here
[Music]
you worry about being openly gay on a
public platform where you could bring
shame to your family and your community
back in the UK but you'll also know that
it's going for the wider community
you represent life will change very
quickly you'll be so bloody glad that
you took on a show that is met with such
acceptance from so many places you'll
never expect that a Pakistani boy would
win an Emmy for being on a show about
being openly gay but that's exactly what
will happen it may seem hard to believe
but one day just doing the things you
love just by being comfortable in your
own skin you will help others live
authentically you'll live your life
completely and openly you will feel
powerful and you'll inspire the world
around you my daughter is a huge fan
show yeah because she says it makes you
feel good about life exactly but isn't
it great though to be celebrated and
applauded for being yourself and doing
what you love yeah we've all had moments
in his word you say you want to
everybody needs to calm the bleep down
yeah and we all get through those - yeah
well done Queer Eye for the straight
guys gonna get one a new viewer this guy
right here like it's a great show